[Music]
model and influencer niece wadehoffer
has died according to tmz niece died by
suicide she was 31 years old the family
confirmed the heartbreaking news in a
statement to tmz writing sadly niece
took her own life after a long battle
with mental health issues law
enforcement reportedly got a call to
check on nice at her houston home last
month upon entering they found her body
the influencer who had a loyal fan base
of over 4 million instagram followers
was known for being a mental health
advocate a topic niece's family
reiterated in their statement
quote she was very open with her
followers about her struggles even
wanting to help followers who also
suffered
[Music]
leading up to her death fans became
worried when niece deleted most of her
instagram page all but three posts were
erased a selfie from march a video from
2017 dancing with her dog to leanne
rime's hit how do i live without you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
niece's final remaining post a throwback
engagement photo from 2015 all smiles
showing off her massive diamond ring in
the caption she wrote from our very
first date i knew this was the man i
want to spend the rest of my life with i
will love you with my entire heart until
my last breath there's also this a cool
experience from 2017. niece
participating in a magic trick with
daniel fernandez in a video that's
amassed nearly 700 000 views no one
could possibly know what it is that
you're thinking of so you drew
this
little diamond piece
what are you thinking of the ring that i
just gave back to my ex well so that was
my decision well fair enough before we
started i gave you an envelope yes oh do
i get it yeah sure please
okay this is when i'm about to freak out
though
and he's even a better artist than me
the family is launching a non-profit
called peace from nice in her honor
benefiting mental health awareness and
research
[Music]
you